who wants to talk about Shakespeare
Gwendoline Christie is about to open in
one of my favorite Shakespeare plays a
midsummer night's dream theater from the
3rd of June to the 31st of August what
can you tell me about this production of
A Midsummer Night's Dream well
interestingly the projects that I tend
to be involved with come with a heavy
cloak of secrecy yes so you would assume
this being Shakespeare that I would be
able to tow everything about the
production but do not be disappointed
yet again I cannot tell you because
there are some surprises involved
I can tell you I'm giving my titania ok
and I can tell you I'm doing some other
things I can tell you that it is
immersive immersive you will be immersed
Jack when you come to see it and all of
you come to see it and all of you come
to see it you will all be immersed is it
audience participation if you're lucky
you've been in Midsummer Night's Dream I
will see it wasn't it yes it was
Sheridan Smith a few years ago in the
West End it's a really fun play to be
part I was so I played bottom and bottom
bits transform it into an ass during the
play which is why I look like that it's
a great play to be part of and also it's
a good I think it's a great one
there's a lot of people's first
Shakespeare isn't it because you can
take kids along to say yeah summer
Night's Dream and it's very much about
joy - there's lots of surprises in our
production but more overly you know you
know in a world full of darkness it's a
it's a bit of much-needed joy it's
twinkling yeah it's in no one no one
dies in it today well we don't know
and this one maybe at the end they all
get murdered by White Walkers and tell
me when you're doing a play like that
obviously there's a live audience and
that brings its challenges have you had
experiences I have had some experience
yes Jack yeah I was doing a production
in the West End some years ago and it
was very unusual sort of production and
that the audience it was a very
different kind of audience people would
come in with takeaway food and eat
takeaway food people hen parties become
a blow-up dolls buying seats for blow-up
dolls and and don't sleep lots of people
seem to be sort of fainting and carried
out on Gurney's but the most spectacular
of all of these things is that one night
some people two people in the balcony
vomited how to the people in the circle
four to six people
vomiting in the stalls was an amazing
night out to the theatre get your
tickets now for the French team to meet
on iTunes
are you sure you want to do an immersive
play you're in the most they could vomit
on you at any moment experiences
[Music]
you